[Music]
even though this has been a crazy year
i just can't help it i'm in the
christmas spirit
i called my mom recently and i said
mommy
i know we're supposed to be apart this
year because there's a pandemic but
i miss you too badly and i've decided to
come home and see you and dad i can't
wait to see you guys this christmas
how should i get there should i take a
plane should i drive what do you think
and this was her reply
[Music]
don't you reach me by railway
don't you reach me by trail away
don't you reach me on an airplane
don't you reach me with your mind
don't you reach me by no care of it
i'll whoop your behind right where you
stand
i don't care how you stay there just
don't come to
my house scared of the virus and won't
let you come in
she will not know there are heels and
mountains
between us thank god there's something
to get over
if i had my way you would not to be
closer
[Music]
was she really this direct she sang the
song word for word
don't you reach me by sailboat don't
climb no tree or swing on no robe
do not make it in a big balloon
at least not until june
i don't care
i don't care i need you right there
right now i need you right there right
now
not by my side no no no
[Music]
dang she sang all that to you it really
hurt my feelings but it sounded really
good
i don't care how you stay there
just don't come
to my house
my mom's saying the same thing
[Music]
[Applause]
you